if you think i'll go back to that
republican congressman for a second if
you think that this woman is kooky
and delusional and unfit for office take
a listen to some of the democrats
rashida talib a member of the squad
took to the house floor the other day to
discuss
uh the riot at the capitol that she was
not present for
and basically turned it into a struggle
session of the new york radical women's
group like something out of the 1970s
she just stood up there and cried
because of how scared she imagined she
could be
on my very first day of orientation
i got my first death threat it was a
serious one they took me aside the fbi
had to go
to the gentleman's home i didn't even
get sworn in yet
when someone wanted me dead for just
existing
more came later uglier more violent
one celebrating and writing the new
zealand massacre
and hoping that more would come another
mentioning my dear son adam
mentioning him by name each one
paralyzed me each time
so what happened on january 6th all i
could do was thank allah
that i wasn't here i felt overwhelming
relief
and i feel bad for alexandria so many of
my colleagues that were here
but as i saw it i thought to myself
thank god
i am not there i saw the images that
they didn't get to see until later
yeah they didn't get to see until later
because they weren't there either aoc
walks up and just puts her hand on her
back while this
lunatic woman is crying what is she
crying over
what is this woman who is supposed to be
a national leader
somewhat a statesman someone with uh
composure
reason uh sort of
elevated or at least normal comportment
what is she crying over
she wasn't there aoc wasn't there either
by the way as we've discussed over the
past uh
couple weeks she was not in the capital
she was in a building down the street
the building was evacuated sure but the
riders were not there
rashida talib is is hysterically crying
at the house floor because she has
received death threats
every single person in public life
especially politics has received death
threats
every one she says she received death
threats because she was existing no
she is receiving death threats because
she's in politics and it's an ugly fact
of politics
but every single person who is in
politics gets death threats
but she got death threats against her
family every single
person who is in any way
even slightly prominent in politics gets
death threats that is part of the job
it's a sad part it's an unfortunate part
if you're not prepared for that if that
if that aspect of the job
if that danger and that unpleasant
interaction
is going to reduce you to a and
hysterical crying lunatic
then you should get out of the job
you're not fit for it compare her
because i think this actually was
genuine i think this woman genuinely is
unhinged
compared to somebody like aoc who i
think is basically as cold as they come
i think she's got ice water running
through her veins
compare her to aoc who then walks up so
this woman
blubbering in this very dishonorable
display
then aoc sees an opportunity and she
just walks up cool as a cucumber puts
her hand on her back poses for the
camera
you know i mean this woman man she is
she is spooky that aoc but i they're not
they're not the same she she recognized
an opportunity here to get herself on
camera and aoc
never misses that at all they used to
say that the most dangerous place in
in washington rather was between chuck
schumer and a tv camera i think aoc
has taken that honor but this is
this is pathetic whatever kooks there
are in the republican party
ain't none of them as kooky as rashida
talib and aoc
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you